you guys ever see like the uh the video
of like the weather lady or I think it
was a dude but she's in water like up to
here and she's like whoa it storms crazy
in her umbrellas like this and then
behind there's just like two college
kids just walking across in the bathroom
why did they [__] do that
[Music]
so did you guys hear that Trump has been
indicted again again again yeah the
third time what's this one for this
one's I think it's for January the sixth
the Insurrection yeah so they're just
you think this wait so the recent one
before this was the Stormy Daniels one
uh right documents document oh yeah the
document yeah the first one was the
Stormy Daniels one what's going on man
because it's so like
I don't understand what do you think's
going on Joe yeah what do you think what
do you think what's your thing what's
your what's the boys think I have
multiple sources that I like to see you
know I like to see mainstream media like
to see private journalism I like to take
different sides because so for some
reason mainstream media seems to be all
in a consensus and there's no other
position but one which makes me go
what's really going on here it's fishing
when multiple companies have one voice
yeah is it it is this is pre-trial so
it's like how can they have a decision
in a position before a verdict
and all the evidence is out so it's like
they predetermined the decision so I was
just like that's so [__] weird
um and it's so conveniently like time to
where the election is coming up
that's the weirdest part and then they
throw all this [__] right before the
election so I'm like what the [__] is
going on yeah I wonder why they did that
you think it's just to set something up
for the election for next year huh no I
don't I think that'd be a conspiracy
it's almost like well I mean the
elections 2024. they had how many years
after he left office to deal with this
[__] does it really take that many years
to throw all these things at them yeah
I'm just like you knew about all of it
during his presidency
so I'm like well I mean January 6 was
yeah that had to happen first and the
documents thing happened after too yeah
every yeah oh yeah after his presidency
but it does seem fishy where Biden
doesn't want to debate
and then the person that he is supposed
to debate is being thrown away you mean
RFK
are you talking about Trump trump the
his leading political opponents yeah his
leading political opponent which is the
that's the scariest part I think for a
lot of people it's like if they see it I
think it's scary I'm not gonna saying a
lot of people I think it's scary yeah
but then the mainstream media Watchers
they're like oh Trump's such a bad guy
like what's happening you know but so
they don't really actually see what's
happening yeah well during okay if
there's already a seating President
right they that party like so like right
now we have Biden and the party
typically doesn't have a primary to
replace the sitting President right
because they have a higher chance of
winning a second term that doesn't
really go down so it's not customary
it's not so then when the Democratic
party and some people want to compete
with Biden like let's say RFK right now
um that makes sense why it's like why
right because everyone's got Biden's
support but on the flip side there has
never been a time where
um uh uh uh there isn't a presidential
debate well there's gonna be debates
eventually right like the primaries is
different because no maybe but then the
actual when when there is there's going
to be a Republican primary yeah and then
once and there'll be a debate between
the the candidates obviously but Biden
wants to sit I don't know yeah he won't
he doesn't want to debate I don't know
what I'm saying they have to though not
in the primary phase during the general
right during the general but he has to
right okay so he can't opt out of that
no not really yeah I mean they did last
run they canceled one of the debates
because Trump got covered if you
remember
yeah but that's different from yeah it's
different from they're supposed to
there's a commission for presidential
debates and they're supposed to do three
yeah
but the the thing that's I think scary
for people is this is your political
opponent and you're trying to imprison
them and that's what makes it gives
people pause if you will right people
like this raise an eyebrow yeah exactly
something's happening over here and what
they're getting him for right they say
he tried to replace the government and
[__] but like in this speech this is the
craziest part in the speech that he gave
on January 6 he says go to the Capitol
peacefully and patriotically what part
of that is like go take it over
[__] and burn it down or
whatever didn't he write on Twitter to
stop certain [__] after they they went
overboard that's like an hour later but
yeah and but this is before anything
happened he says go peacefully and
patriotically and everything every time
that I see reporting on this topic I
never see that included and it's [__]
I've never even heard that exactly when
when we were at January 6th they told
everybody was very calm everybody was
walking through real chill and it wasn't
as crazy as it was on the news yeah when
you were there like it was totally chill
Joe when Nick was out there waving the
swastika and he was calling me
[Laughter]
I'm glad Nick actually opened up and
told us a real story about himself yeah
this is the year I'm not gonna deflect
anymore that's awesome dude you picked a
good topic for that I picked a good
timing for that too yeah the Rally's
starting in Pasadena we just rode that
thing off the Martyr of JK news it
begins now
but yeah peacefully patriotically you've
never heard of it right
this is why I was conflicted is because
like
I I followed the I was watching what was
happening I saw the tweet and then I was
like when they're reporting it it's
different from what actually happened
and I'm like why why are they doing this
like why what's the point of
either omitting or redirecting or
rephrasing I'm just I'm like what's the
what's the end goal here I just prefer
it when they like they don't treat us
like we're little kids and they just
give you all the information and let you
decide for yourself but ever since that
day it's like here's how it is and
here's why it was the worst thing that
ever happened in the world and you just
need to know what's the worst thing that
ever happened and I'm like okay but
you're telling me it's the worst thing
ever happened just give me all the
information yeah yeah or just show the
footage because like it's one of it's
like the weirdest thing when you can
just tell that everybody's wanting it to
seem worse than it is and then on the
flip side you can live by a riot and you
see the coverage versus what you saw
with your own eyes and they're making it
to be mostly peaceful yeah because if
you see the footage from the hallways
it's like the the people that storm the
capital and the cops are just walking
people it's like a tour guide yeah
there's like walking pieces yeah it
looked like he was showing him where the
bathroom was and that's like Norm
Macdonald had a Tweet back then like
because we could all watch it live it
was happening on people's cell phones
and [__] and he said I love when the
violent terrorists were respecting The
Velvet ropes
yeah I mean it's not to say that like
that [__] isn't supposed to happen or
that it wasn't bad but like let it be
what it is yeah like stop being like oh
look at we need to remember this day
forever I think that's what I don't like
is how the media is trying to tell us
how to think which makes me resist their
narrative even more and go what the [__]
really happened and then when the real
footage comes out and the guy with the
raccoon hat is just hanging out with a
cop and they're just walking through
hallways and they're looking around I do
think like so so I would say I would say
what happened was disrespectful it was
[__] up it's still [__] it's like
the riot car was [__] up like the
breaking windows and like yeah yeah that
[__] was [__] up but did they storm
the capital if they try to replace the
government
yeah no it was a bunch of [__] did a
couple grandmas fall off uh you know
some buildings yeah a little bit you
guys ever see like the uh
video of like the weather lady or I
think it was a dude but she's in water
like up to here and she's like whoa
[__] Storm's crazy in her umbrellas
like this and then behind there's just
like two college kids just walking
across in the bathroom
why did they [__] do that good view
Anderson Cooper got caught doing that
too he was like in a canoe he's like
it's [__] crazy out here and same
[__] there's like a truck in the
background just driving with like a
little bit of water on the tires it's
like there's what the [__] dude it's
drama yeah it sells it's the opposite
part that that just bugs me more because
like on Melrose my friend had a shoe
store next to the Starbucks on Melrose
and Stanley his whole store got burned
down during the BLM rights imagine what
it feels like to be him watching the
news act like it didn't happen yeah and
and act like everything was fine and you
lost your whole livelihood him and his
father have had that store for like 40
years and he had to move because they
didn't have any other police
and they're on a lease that existed from
so long ago that he can't get that kind
of four yeah so it's like he he's out of
the business and and he has to watch
people act like oh everything was fine
it was just a bunch of like no nothing
happened no no nothing broke out like
dude that place was charred and it was
gone and for no reason he was not even a
a a Republican but it just I just own a
shoe store yeah yeah he just happened to
be there trying to sell some shoes and
the stupidest thing is that he's next
door to the Starbucks which they could
have burned that [__] down wow but they
didn't because it wasn't about trying to
like stick it to any corporate man it's
just a [__] random ass thing yeah
yeah I think like regardless of you know
politics right
what's probably the worst thing that's
hurting America is mainstream media
because they just care about clicks it's
a business yeah they need views they
need clicks they need to do the most
extreme [__] to make people scared to
make people think a certain way so
they'll watch they'll stay glued to the
television whatever and um
they they have no like accountability
for the damage that they do to Americans
so like whatever narrative they have to
sensationalize or make it crazy or maybe
they don't like a certain dude because
like you know they're sponsored by
Pfizer and this guy's talking about [__]
about the vaccine or whatever and
instead of just having like a let them
speak freely so we can make the decision
on our own they're like let's stamp them
out because our sponsors aren't going to
like this or whatever it is right and
then now like I think we growing up at
least for me I've always was like why
the [__] do people like journalists do
this on the news where they interrupt
they disrupt the person that they're
interviewing it's so [__] rude they
don't let them speak and then I'm like I
like this new form where people just
have conversations and you can hear the
thoughts of the person they're trying to
interview instead of being an obnoxious
interviewer who's trying to build like a
narrative right another one is like the
announcer voice and I know there was
like a standard style of Journalism
where people would do it but it's so
[__] fake that I think like a lot of
us just tune out when we hear that okay
even when Rhonda Santa starts talking
I'm like look I don't hate Ron DeSantis
because he was better on Kobe than most
Governors yeah especially our [__]
Governor but that politician double
speak all that [__] when I hear the
voice and the tone and the tenor and I
just it just reminds me of every
politician like in the 90s and 2000s
that I heard and like and especially in
the slogans right yeah like aren't you
being a Putin apologist or a Russian
pro-russian sympathizer it's the same
[__] during the 90s and two during the
2000s when they're like like oh well I
wish you'd stick up for the American
people I could stick up for Saddam
Hussein and then they get thunderous
Applause right like it's so easy to
[__] just accuse your opponent of
like the worst thing we were re-watching
some of the debates and we you just when
you're watching it you realize you're
like [__] this is how our country
figures out who the next leader is gonna
be like is there it's like it's like a
panel of like dudes who are 40 and up
right they're don't ask man and they're
just talking over each other being as
Petty as they can [__] stabbing you
here not even having a real conversation
and everyone's going [__] nuts
anytime they say a slogan like like that
and it's just like what is it because
money is driving everything yeah yeah
you know what I realized though I think
the reason why our generation and
younger is not really getting with that
is because the boomer generation and and
and their world was very corporate so
like the level of professionalism like
when you work in a big company that's
how they speak those are the ways they
fight uh it's a different culture yeah
yeah so normal guys like us Blue Collar
World whatever like when we have
conversations with people we don't do
that [__] so then in their world if
you're like middle class and above and
like you're in that environment they
speak like that that water cooler talk
that [__] whatever they do that
boardroom [__] like that's their way of
communicating so I think like when
you're in that space that's just you
just see it's just a different face that
they have yeah so but the more of us
that don't work for these major
institutions and whatever we don't
[__] play that game we're just like
we get to be who we are yeah so we're
like [__] [__] these guys [__] the news
[__] these [__] snobby little
corporate [__] like we're not gonna
listen to any of these fakers yeah and
then now you have like Joe Rogan
alternative media people just having
real conversations you have politicians
that are actually talking about things
that people care about there's a
counterculture and it's actually
successful and I think there's like
anti-establishment and now there's
establishment I actually don't see it as
Republican and Democrat I see it as
people that are a part of this old world
and this old system versus disruptors
that are coming in and I fee I see a
battle on on both sides well that's why
like RFK is like he's kind of popping
off because he's one of the only guys
that's actually doing long form podcasts
so when people who are our generation
listen to them talk they go oh well I
don't see any other traditional
politicians yeah so then you're like
okay I can understand that and I think
that's the reason why people like like
Trump so much because he does resonate
really well with probably caller folks
because when you hear him talk he's not
a traditional no and he answers
questions and he doesn't have a like a
prepared script he just says it he's
like we took the oil yeah took the oil
he definitely who says that that's
[__] that's wild that he's saying he
is yeah like he has his own style of
slogans but it's different enough where
it's like oh this guy's different so you
get his you see it's like okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think so a
lot of people [__] hate Trump for
good reasons right
and I would say like I have no feelings
of love or hate toward people I've never
met it's just what they represent but I
if I had to say something positive of
what he did to our politics and
everything is he brought real
conversations and what I mean by real
conversations is this [__] fake
double speak [__] that politicians do
when he was asked and they try to Corner
him about all the stuff right do you
remember even David Dave Chappelle said
this where he was like yeah the system's
corrupt I [__] benefit from it I use
it and then he goes and if you guys want
the tax laws changed just ask her
Hillary yeah hurt her buddies
and he points to the donors
and then I'm like he invited Juanita
Broderick to the [__] debate the
chick that um says that Bill Clinton
raped her yeah that was the most
gangster [__] I've ever seen that's and
then for me I'm like this is exactly
what we need it's like accountability
from these [__] lying ass politicians
that's what we never get right that are
like okay you guys are doing this wrong
you guys are doing this wrong and I'm
like yeah but you guys are benefiting
from all the things that you're
condemning others for and people can't
see that and they dude remember when
Trump said Obama is spying on me and
everyone's like this guy's [__]
stupid this is so dumb that's all been
proven yes Obama was spying on him they
were literally spying on his campaign
they put uh operatives in his campaign
like feds in his in his campaign to spy
on his campaign and then they the steel
dossier that that document that says he
he hired hookers and all this [__] and
like he was peeing on hookers in Russia
or whatever that was all [__] and it
was all paid for by the Hillary Clinton
campaign and he was saying all that back
then too and they said he's [__]
stupid for that and that's a conspiracy
theory that's all been 100 proven but
nobody gives a [__] and it's like not
even a scandal that's why I hate the
whole like regardless of what
politicians are saying I hate the filter
that has to go through mainstream media
on what actually gets reported yeah yeah
they're picking Jews can't just give you
the info yeah mainstream media will
never talk about Logan Paul without
bringing up the Japan [__] they'll never
talk about PewDiePie without bringing up
the Jew [__] but they'll talk about
something Biden just said about his
stance on gays without bringing up what
it used to be they'll talk about
something Kamala said about the black
community without bringing up stuff that
happened with weed where she
incarcerated a ton of blood just erase
the [__] pass but then you can see
what side they're on yeah yeah and it's
like so clear like now more than ever
it's like kind of tiring that's why
people really aren't watching them
anymore honestly I mean they watch them
more than us unfortunately but but
that's why Tucker is like going crazy
like his [__] is going through yeah
Tucker's more of like a YouTuber than a
[__] reporter what I like okay so
what I liked about Tucker is he admitted
I was a part of the media problem yeah
he was like I actually supported the war
in Iraq
I supported the war in Afghanistan I I I
was like we need to get a Revenge
because I believed all that [__] and he
goes now I understand like we went in
there for nothing he's trying to make
reparations that's so human of him I've
never heard that accountability for any
spots imagine George W actually saying
that instead of saying like we we had to
and I don't believe that I don't believe
it's pandering either because it's so
not to his benefit in every direction to
say that yeah like he's [__] himself
in other ways by admitting that so I
don't think it's like it's not a pattern
to me I'm like oh okay there's an
expense remember when Obama's only
Scandal was a tan suit
how dare he but you know what's crazy to
me is like we love RFK yeah and he's
Democrat right but someone will listen
to this conversation and think we're a
bunch of [__] right right-wingers and
then you know they're trying to paint
Robert F Kennedy as a right-winger when
he's a Democrat his whole [__] life
like Ryan's saying he's now an
anti-semite every time they mention him
he's an answer by now yeah why is that
because he said he got he was at a
dinner and he talked about how
um there's a report that kovid was
bioengineered to attack certain races
but it excluded Ashkenazi Jews or
whatever and he's just stating a fact
from a report and they're like that's
anti-semitic because basically someone
engineered kovid to kill everyone but
the juice but it it was he's he said
another group too he said the Jewish and
another group and then they forget they
conveniently forget but he's talking
about somebody else's report that's like
us talking about something that we read
on JK and they're like this is what they
think
because it said in an article